we're told the first four terms of an
arithmetic sequence are given so it goes
from negative 8 to negative 14 to
negative 20 to negative 26. what is the
fifth term in the sequence so we just
need to figure out the next term well an
arithmetic sequence each each successive
term is separated by the same amount so
when we go from negative 8 to negative
14 we went down by 6 and then we go down
by 6 again to go to negative 20. and
then we go down by 6 again to go to
negative 26 and so we're going to go
down by 6 again to get to negative 32
negative
32.
let's do a couple more of these
the first five terms of the sequence are
given what is the sixth term let's see
to go from two to negative one you
subtracted three
two minus three is negative one
negative one minus three is negative
four negative four minus three is
negative seven negative seven minus
three is negative ten and so negative 10
minus 3 is negative 13.
so hopefully that gives you
the hang of things